i will call this committee a conference
on house bill 2022 to order
and if the senate would allow i would i
would like to just talk briefly about
the changes yeah
move sorry about that
i love this arrangement that we have
um
and just where we could possibly reach
agreement and where we're not probably
going to reach some agreements
um
first
house bill 1269
passed the house
our last session
in that it does eliminate
the
scenic and cultural
byways council so the language that you
have in there is good to keep something
going so that the department and and
and somebody is looking at at those
byways now that the council is being
disbanded
so we
that's a good move correct um that was a
recommendation by dot because they're
doing the the updates and upkeeps anyway
so while the um
the committee is no longer there they
will continue doing the upgrades so
that's they had requested that it be in
there i i know talking to members who
who put that 1269 together um they had
worked for several years on how to which
councils and commissions to get rid of
and this was one that had not met for
years right so um
representative ebel called me over the
weekend to make sure i understood that
even though i was the co-sponsor of the
bill
the second one uh the remote language
for the transportation council
the house would prefer that that
language for remote
meetings of the council itself as far as
quorum and the rest be removed we have
either killed or tabled several bills in
the last couple of weeks that dealt with
remote um
meetings and the
reason that we
there's i think what is it 14 14 members
i'm on the new hampshire transportation
council there are 14 members on there
two of the more most important ones we
have
rad nichols
who has major health issues but he's a
important part part of it
so he can't come in now connie crawford
was recruited to come in by the
commissioner she's an expert in
transportation technology and transit
but she's out of new jersey but she is a
member so that's why
in order to maintain and be able to vote
i'd like to keep
allow those two to
um
[Music]
vote
and com part be part of our quorum
and as i said the house would prefer
that to come out
guys
yay nay
okay
yeah that's
there there are a couple others that
i've noticed that have gone through
um so
we can accept that
okay
now we'll get to the hardwoods
i know um
the the floor amendment that was added
about ev infrastructure funding
the house tabled the identity almost
identical bill at our last session
um the house will insist that that come
out of the 10-year plan
i'll just if i may say a word mr
chairman about that is that we did take
out the creation of a fund
in the this version of the amendment but
by any other definition i've talked with
house ways and means and house finance
and the way it's worded
it is a dedicated fund by any other name
since it it
does not go through fiscal or anything
else it just goes to the commissioner
and out
we prefer to have it go through the
existing systems that are there either
fiscal committee or the 10-year plan
well thank you mr chairman i do believe
that many of the projects in the 10-year
plan is the federal requirements of
funding that have sent this to d.o.t to
be spent the advantageous
advantage of having this language in
statute is that it clarifies the
priorities which indeed are governor
sununu's priorities and how we spend ev
funding and also clarifies or reinforces
the right of the commissioner to hire
um an outside contractor so it really is
kind of practical i think it ran into
the kind of anything about eevee is not
so good
uh feeling but um
there it is i mean the money's gonna get
spent anyways but this is a wiser way to
do it
the the other thing um that when i did
talk to the commissioner um she said
granted it's not necessarily needed for
the federal funds because the 10-year
plan actually authorizes them but if
there are any grants that are available
from the state or
other grants available
they would need they would need some
kind of fund to put it in
um
the house still would prefer that that
it come out
okay and then the final and then after
we'll caucus okay hopefully ruth will be
back and and there is one that the house
will walk on
if it is not included is the
um
ownership of continental boulevard that
was fought on the house floor
it is the house position
and we will defend that house position
and as a senate the senate position is
to keep it um keep it with the d.o.t
at least for the time being
um where they still own
oh
money on it and i think at least for the
time being it needs to stay exactly
where it is and that's the center
position
the house and senate seem to be in
disagreement i don't think that any of
the house members are going to change
so i think our continuing to to meet is
probably
counterproductive
we have a one-minute recess yep
all right we're we're back in session
that there is still no agreement on
either of those two
issues i assume senator
uh we will we will pull out the um ev
fund okay thank you so the the the sole
issue that is left for a resolution
is the ownership of continental
boulevard
um we all need to take a break for a
minute
um i would suggest
if the senate is amenable
to a 10 30 uh meeting on wednesday may
18th uh room to be determined because i
don't have this room full time uh
is that amenable
to and it's amenable to the house
and i think both of us will be talking
with our respective leadership um so
with that the committee of conference on
house bill 2022
is in recess
until wednesday
at 10 30 a.m thank you all for coming
thank you
you